[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten guten abend
die sichere existenz israels ist
deutsche staatsräson eine leitlinie
deutscher politik sie erwächst aus der
historischen verantwortung deutschlands
für den holocaust die ermordung von
sechs millionen juden durch das
nazi-regime ein monströses wie
singuläres verbrechen wenn der präsident
der palästinenser dieses verbrechen
relativiert und mehr noch israel als
potenziert das nazi deutschland
darstellt ist das unerträglich ein
skandal ist es wenn diese worte im
deutschen kanzleramt fallen und
unwidersprochen bleiben geschehen
gestern abend in berlin heute ging es um
schadensbegrenzung
frank buchwald berichtet ein
diplomatischer eklat wie dieser
geschieht selten auf der berliner bühne
zu gast im kanzleramt mahmud abbas
präsident der palästinensischen
autonomiebehörde zwei statements
sachfragen routine eigentlich was aber
ließ gleich zu beginn eine minutenlange
tirade vom blatt wirft israel apartheid
vor scholz widerspricht etwa steiner
termine ich will ausdrücklich hier an
dieser stelle sagen dass ich mir das
wort apartheid nicht zu eigen mache und
dass ich das nicht für richtig halte für
die beschreibung der situation dann
stellt ein journalist eine frage 50
jahre nach münchen
1972 nach dem attentat palästinensischer
terroristen auf israelische sportler
fahren sie 50 jahre danach als präsident
im namen der palästinenser sich bei
israel und deutschland zu entschuldigen
und bei der vollständigen aufklärung des
anschlags behilflich zu sein
aber setzt nach bezichtigt israel des
50-fachen holocaust an den palästinenser
haben viel holz der kanzler sprachlos
keine gegenrede und dann auch noch der
übliche anschlag für die fotografen denn
klar ist perfekt also ich bin der
meinung ist er richtig gewesen
unmittelbar nach diesen unsäglichen
äußerungen seines kanzlers sofort ein
statement abzugeben ein klares statement
und ich halte es auch für etwas
problematisch zu ende der
pressekonferenz einen freundschaftlichen
handschlag zu machen dieses bild in
israel heute auf allen titelseiten
ausgerechnet deutschland ausgerechnet in
berlin der diplomatische schaden kaum zu
erfassen zumal europa den palästinensern
jährlich millionenhilfen zahlt das müsse
nun endlich folgen haben fordert die
deutsch-israelische gesellschaft die
konsequenz muss sein dass deutschland
keine gelder mehr an die
palästinensische autonomiebehörde
überweist solange diese märtyrer renten
an terroristen bezahlt
schadensbegrenzung die verantwortung
übernimmt der regierungssprecher ja aber
die pressekonferenz zu früh beendet sie
haben gesehen dass der bundeskanzler
mich beim abgang von der bühne schon
kurzem angeraunzt hat dass ich das etwas
schnell gemacht habe und er gerne noch
etwas entgegnet hätte scholz meldet sich
per twitter er sei zutiefst empört über
die unsäglichen aussagen von abbas
übersetzt auch auf englisch und
hebräisch der opposition reicht das
nicht man hätte wirklich direkt
reagieren müssen alles was jetzt im
nachhinein kommt es einfach zu spät
viele deutsche juden die seit jahren
einen wachsenden antisemitismus auch
hier beobachten reagieren alarmiert
wir haben demonstrationen dieses jahr
und letztes jahr gesehen wo einfach
nicht israel kritik sondern hass
geäußert wurde und wo auch juden und
israel gleich behandelt worden sind in
einen topf geworfen sind und einfach mit
massiven aggressionen überzogen worden
sind das ist eine folge von solchen
äußerungen und so wirkt ein kalkulierter
tabubruch von abbas auch auf die debatte
in deutsch
ja und die aufarbeitung ist noch nicht
zu ende schauen wir nach berlin und nach
tel aviv beginnen wir bei chuck unter
der bahn ag in berlin die wellen
schlugen hoch was hat scholz mit seinem
nachträglichen krisen-management jetzt
heute ausrichten können gesondert heute
zumindest so entschlossen reagiert dass
er schaden begrenzen kann es ist ihm
schon gelungen den eindruck zurück zu
holen dass man in deutschland in berlin
neben dem bund bundeskanzler stehen kann
und den holocaust gänzlich
unwidersprochen relativieren kann aber
er tut es eben nur nachträglich und die
klare haltung die er heute zeigt die
macht noch einmal sehr deutlich wie sehr
er sich da selber gestern vielleicht
auch im weg gestanden hat denn es steht
die frage im raum warum hat er sich
gestern nicht über das protokoll
hinweggesetzt als bundeskanzler kann im
kanzleramt natürlich auch das ende einer
pressekonferenz aufschieben damit
brüskiert er vielleicht sein
pressesprecher aber er hätte gestern ist
klar zumindest verhindern können und es
gibt auch die frage warum man
ausgerechnet im fünfzigsten jahr des
olympia attentat von palästinensern auf
israelis in münchen einladen musste auch
mit verbalen entgleisungen musste ja
gerechnet werden bei diesem gast ist das
kanzleramt zu blauäugig mit einem
erwartbar schwierigen abbas umgegangen
völlig blauäugig kann das umfeld von
olaf scholz da eigentlich nicht gewesen
sein das kann man an der antwort von
olaf scholz auf die den apartheids
vorwurf ablesen denn darauf ist er
vorbereitet gewesen das heißt man wusste
dass da also ein schwieriger gast kommt
allerdings muss man dann auch nochmal
auf den terminkalender schauen und
fragen warum saß der termin an diesem
tag olaf scholz ist gestern von einer
doch sehr dicht gedrängten auslandsreise
zurückgekommen er war gerade erst
gelandet erwartete aber das praktisch
schon im kanzleramt das ist schon eine
sportliche leistung die kann man einen
bundeskanzler zutrauen aber es ist eben
sehr sehr eng getaktet und in dem fall
ist es nicht wirklich gut gegangen das
hätte man vielleicht etwas umsichtiger
planen können den körper in tel aviv der
aufschrei ist in israel groß wir haben
die zeitungsschlagzeilen gesehen wenn
wenn scholz nun morgen das ist ja
geplant mit premierminister lappi
telefoniert das bekommt er da zu hören
was was erwartet israel nun vom
deutschen bundeskanzler
israel erwartet natürlich eine klare
haltung gegenüber dieser entgleisung
gleichzeitig muss man feststellen heute
hat ihr kein führender politiker auch
kein regierungsmitglied die reaktion von
olaf scholz inklusive handschlag
überhaupt kritisiert ich denke dass das
entsetzen und die empörung über diese
worte des palästinenserpräsidenten sind
hier einfach viel zu groß
problematisch könnte für die
bundesregierung aber noch der kontext
werden in dem die worte fielen da ging
es ja um die frage eines journalisten
nach einer entschuldigung von abbas für
den terroranschlag von münchen 1972
dieses thema der gedenk tag der am 5
september an steht der hat hier große
wellen geschlagen in den letzten tagen
weil die hinterbliebenen der opfer und
auch staatspräsident herzog ihre
teilnahme an der gedenkveranstaltung in
münchen abgesagt haben der grund die
diskussion um entschädigungszahlungen
und akteneinsicht die slot israelischer
seite bis heute nicht gegeben hat dass
diese diskussion jetzt in den kontext
einer holocaust relativierung im
deutschen kanzleramt fällt das könnte
noch unangenehm werden außerdem olaf
scholz sich die frage gefallen lassen
müssen warum r präsident abbas so kurz
vor dem jahrestag eingeladen hat genau
deshalb muss es aufgabe ausgeräumt
werden noch mal nach berlin schack und
aller die frage ist eben wird es auch
weitere konkrete konsequenzen geben wir
haben es gehört es gibt die forderungen
auch den palästinensern
finanzielle zuschüsse zu kürzen diese
diskussion ist in deutschland nicht ganz
neu die schwelt eigentlich schon länger
weil ja auch die palästinensische
autonomiebehörde nicht erst gestern
anlass zur kritik gegeben hat da gibt es
viele punkte die kritikwürdig sind und
auch immer wieder diskutiert werden in
der vergangenheit hat das nicht dazu
geführt dass die unterstützung die er
letztlich der palästinensischen
bevölkerung zugute kommen soll gänzlich
eingestellt wird es wäre überraschend
wenn es diesmal dazu kenne dankeschön
für die einordnungen aus tel aviv und
aus berlin
ja die nahost politik ist ein
schwieriges feld schauen wir auf das
größere bild in der regionen lässt heute
eine meldung aufhorchen israel und die
türkei nehmen nach jahre langer eiszeit
wieder vollständige diplomatische
beziehungen auf wirtschaft handel
tourismus das sind gemeinsame interessen
die jetzt intensiver verfolgt werden
sollen dabei gilt präsident erdogan
eigentlich als fürsprecher der
palästinenser und will das auch bleiben
aber er ist auch ein meister des spagats
und sucht die profilierung als
vermittler das zeigt sich auch im
ukraine krieg morgen trifft erdogan
zusammen mit uno generalsekretär gute
risch den ukrainischen präsidenten als
nato-mitglied unterstützt die türkei die
ukraine nicht ohne zugleich die nähe zu
russland zu suchen über erdogan
schaukelpolitik berichtet florian
neumann
in der welt der nato werbefilmchen sieht
das alles so glänzend aus die türkei
mitten in der nato immer dabei zu wasser
zu land in der luft
wir sind alliierte heißt es da
sind sie das immer noch in der welt der
harten geopolitik zweifelt mancher wenn
sich der türkische präsident erdogan
zuletzt gleich zweimal mit dem
kriegsherrn putin aus russland trifft
wenn er dann von vertiefte
zusammenarbeit spricht und so die frage
aufwirft auf welcher seite die türkei
eigentlich spielt die türkei ist nicht
neutral sie ist aufs engste
wirtschaftlich militär politisch und
darüber hinaus auch strategisch mit der
russischen förderation verknüpft sie
trägt die wirtschaftlichen sanktionen
nicht mit die der westen verabschiedet
hat und
versuchte eine art von balance akt
erdogans ballung sagt es ist eine
schaukel politik zwischen dem westen und
russland
da ist die eine seite die türkei liefert
bewaffnete drohnen an die ukraine sie
sperrt den bosporus für russische
kriegsschiffe und erdogan vermittelt den
getreide die erst durch schiffe mit
lebensmitteln verlassen die ukraine
immerhin
eine politik für die erdogan
ausschließlich anerkennung bekäme wäre
dann nicht die andere seite von
sanktionen gegen russland will man in
der türkei nichts wissen lässt sich
stattdessen mehr gas liefern bezahlt
natürlich in russischen rubel und setzt
auf mehr handel mit russland
ausgerechnet jetzt
erdogan der autokrat in den reihen der
nato sucht die nähe von putin weil er
ado an ihn offenbar braucht in einem
anderen konflikt syrien berichtet ein
ehemaliger türkischer diplomat
in syrien will die türkische regierung
um jeden preis eine neue humanitäre
katastrophe verhindern die einen
erneuten zustrom von flüchtlingen
auslösen könnten
hier verlässt sich die türkei darauf
dass moskau auf die regierung in syrien
ein wirklich
möglich dass es nicht allein um edle
humanitäre fragen geht sondern wie hier
im frühjahr 2020 um einen angriff der
türkei auf kurden im norden syriens
worüber seit wochen spekuliert wird und
europa sieht hilflos zu wie die türkei
dem westen entgleitet man ist
schließlich selbst auf die regierung
erdogan angewiesen ob bei der nato nord
erweiterung oder der flüchtlingsfrage
meinen dass es an der zeit ist dass man
nicht nur mit worten und appellen
sondern letztendlich mit taten die
türkische regierung daran erinnert dass
ein verlässlicher partner anders agiert
im bündnis als es die türkei gegenwärtig
tut
1952 trat die türkei der nato bei 70
jahre später steht sie bestenfalls am
rande des bündnisses immer noch besser
so sagen viele in brüssel als ganz
draußen
mit der lage in der ukraine beginnen nun
die nachrichten mit gundula gause an
diesem
175 tag des russischen angriffskrieges
sind wieder mehrere orte im osten und
süden der ukraine beschossen worden
unübersichtlich ist die lage an dem von
russen besetzten ukrainischen
atomkraftwerks abriss ja offenbar wird
auch dort weiterhin gekämpft russische
langstreckenbomber feuerten raketen auf
eine ferienhausanlage bei odessa ab bei
angriffen auf taxis sollen sechs
menschen getötet worden sein in nicola
wurden wohnhäuser und infrastruktur
beschädigt nach ukrainischen angaben
kommt die russische offensive nicht
voran
bei einem bürgerdialog im
brandenburgischen neuruppin ist
bundeskanzler scholz auf lautstärke
gegendemonstranten gestoßen er musste
sich gegen sprechchöre und pfeifkonzerte
durchsetzen zu den aktionen hatten die
ard und die linke aufgerufen trotz der
proteste bekräftigte scholz seine
regierung plane weitere maßen namen im
kampf gegen inflation und hohe
energiekosten
ein ausführlicher bericht später im
update
in der sogenannten comics affäre haben
staatsanwälte auch e-mails der
büroleiterin von kanzler scholz geprüft
nach berichten verschiedener medien sind
dabei mehrere nachrichten in bezug auf
datenlöschung als auffällig bewertet
worden bei den ermittlungen geht es um
eine mögliche einflussnahme auf die
steuerliche behandlung der hamburger
warburg bank dazu muss ich kanzler
scholz am freitag vor einem
untersuchungsausschuss der hansestadt
äußern er war zu der betreffenden zeit
dort erster bürgermeister in berlin
charlottenburg ist ein brandanschlag auf
das wahlkreisbüro der grünen
bundesfamilienministerin lisa paus
verübt worden wie die polizei mitteilt
wurde in unmittelbarer nähe das kürzel
nsu gefunden ob es einen zusammenhang
mit der tat gibt prüft der staatsschutz
ministerin pauls reagierte auf twitter
schockiert stellte aber auch klar sie
werde sich nicht einschüchtern lassen
bei der ursachensuche für das
massenhafte fischsterben in der oder
haben wissenschaftler eine giftige algen
art in den blick genommen diese hat sich
im fluss rasant entwickelt unklar sei
aber so die forscher ob das gift der
alge der grund für das fischsterben sei
polnische und deutsche untersuchungen
konnten bislang keine schwermetalle oder
quecksilber im flusswasser nachweisen im
stettiner haff sind aktuell noch keine
auswirkungen zu spüren
deutschland wartet auf den regen aber
selten so willkommen die böden
knochentrocken flüsse werden zu
rinnsalen und vielerorts sinken nun auch
die grundwasserspiegel das wasser ein
knappes gut er ist diese einsicht ist
hierzulande nicht sehr verbreitet musste
es nicht sein aber spätestens in diesem
sommer wird manchem klar das sparen an
wertvollen trinkwasser wird künftig wohl
zum alltag gehören isabel de la vega mit
einem situationsbericht aus hessen im
hessischen grävenwiesbach zitiert
traktor in der mittagshitze seine spur
durch staub und trockenheit die
taunusgemeinde hat ein problem es fehlt
an wasser wir haben kaum niederschläge
wir können kaum wasser generieren aus
den oberflächennahen gewinnungs anlagen
die doch einen erheblichen anteil machen
mehr als 50 60 prozent der
wasserversorgung und das macht sich
natürlich auch bemerkbar bei dem angebot
an trinkwasser wenn dafür bereitstellen
können
5600 einwohner zählt grävenwiesbach
mitte juni musste der bürgermeister den
sogenannten trinkwasser notstand
ausrufen immer wieder erklärt er die
massnahmen es ist verboten den garten
mit trink also leitungswasser zu
bewässern oder das auto zu waschen so
sieht es hier überall aus wir haben auch
fische und da ist natürlich auch die
befürchtung dass sie jetzt lange ohne
frisches wasser auch nicht mehr
durchhalten hier von solchen flächen um
den ort herum kommt der größte teil des
trinkwassers der regen versickert und
speist unterirdische röhren mit wasser
und landet hier normalerweise sprudelt
es aus diesem rohr nur so heraus jetzt
ein rinnsal
umfangreichen baumfällungen wegen des
borkenkäfers haben das trinkwasser
problem verschlimmert wenn aber wie hier
der wald kaputt ist und der weg ist dann
brennt die sonne gnadenlos auf den boden
und das eher wenig an feuchtigkeit kann
nicht versickern sondern verdunstet
automat denn trinkwasser fehlt droht ein
verteilungskampf um das knappe gut im
nahen vogelsbergkreis ist es bereits
soweit die region liefert wasser an die
metropole frankfurt doch auch im
vogelsberg sinken die wasservorräte
frankfurt wird dennoch weiter versorgt
und dort ist sparen nicht verpflichtend
das sorgt für ärger man sieht das dann
mit unserem wasser es ist ja unser
wasser es wird in unserer region
gewonnen in frankfurt sportfelder oder
auch einfach nur vorgärten gewässert
werden das ist ja unser trinkwasser das
ist ein wahnsinnig wertvolles
lebensmittel dann macht einen das
natürlich betroffen
trinkwasser müsste per bundesgesetz
eingespart und in häusern eine
wiederverwertung vorschrift werden das
fordert sie
die frage wird sein ob man über eine
gewisse mindestmenge an wasser gebraucht
pro person am tag darüber hinaus die
gebühren deutlich erhöhen wird um zu
sagen alles was und ob es ist luxus das
muss ja wirklich mit eurem geld bezahlen
vorerst heißt es hier weiter wasser
sparen die gemeinde hat den notstand
gerade verlängert bis ende september
tja neue verteilungskämpfe das führt
auch zum nächsten thema denn auf
deutschen straßen tobt ein kampf einfach
leute haben einnahmen dafür
verkehrsdichte stress der öffentliche
raum ist vor allem in den städten
überbucht von autos bussen fahrrädern
die scooter das führt zu konflikten und
zu unfällen gerade bei den radfahrern
370 tote und fast 15.000 schwerverletzte
weiß die bilanz des letzten jahres aus
daran muss sich etwas ändern wie der
zunehmende radverkehr mit mehr
sicherheit verbunden werden kann darüber
berät ab morgen der sechzigste
verkehrsgerichtstag in goslar und
christian von rechenberg zeigt das ist
auch nötig vor knapp zwei wochen ist es
passiert wieder einmal fahrrad gegen lkw
an einer baustelleneinfahrt in nürnberg
die frau auf dem rad stirbt wir auf zwei
rädern unterwegs ist lebt gefährlich die
zahl der verletzten und toten im
straßenverkehr in deutschland sinkt seit
20 jahren außer bei den radfahrern
das unfall thema spielt sich im
wesentlichen im kreuzungsbereich ab
immer da wo man sich zwangsläufig
begegnet kommt es zu problemen die
lösung sieht unter anderem so ausbreite
radstraßen autos hier nur zu gast platz
zum ausweichen münster macht es vor und
nennt den preis da muss das auto
beispielsweise auch parkraum abkleben
zugunsten werden des umweltverbundes
oder hier wie in diesem falle zu gunsten
des fahrrades raum abgeben soll das auto
also oder langsam machen das ringen um
den öffentlichen raum hat begonnen und
die straßenverkehrsordnung ist noch auf
seiten der autofahrer gerichte
genehmigen dem rad zu lasten des autos
nämlich meist nur dann der raum wenn die
gemeinde eine gefahr für die sicherheit
der räder an konkreter stelle nachweisen
kann und zwar durch verkehrszählungen
und unfallstatistik viele projekte
scheitern deswegen kritik kommt aus den
ländern hier sieht man den bund in der
pflicht
zunächst einmal würde ich erwarten dass
das bundesverkehrsministerium jetzt
rangeht und die straßenverkehrsordnung
des straßenverkehrs gesetz novelliert
das ist sozusagen aus den 60er jahren
also das ist überholt und in der
straßenverkehrsordnung sollten wir eben
auch regnen haben die zum beispiel den
radverkehr erleichtern belange wie klima
gesundheit und städtebauliche
entwicklung sollen hinzukommen so steht
sogar im koalitionsvertrag
keine gute idee sagt der adac ohne frage
sind das wahnsinnig wesentliche ziele
aber in der straßenverkehrs gesetzgebung
haben sie aus unserer sicht keinen platz
es gibt andere gesetze die dafür
verantwortlich sind klimaschutz
voranzubringen grenzwerte festzulegen
und dort ist es auch richtig der
bundesverkehrsminister verweist indes
auf erste reformen der
straßenverkehrsordnung und auf
förderprogramme doch die experten sind
bestenfalls ein anfang beispiel baden
württemberg das radnetz ist noch immer
voller lücken und veraltete abschnitte
der rückstand zu ländern wie den
niederlanden betrage stolze 15 jahre
also wenn wir den rückstand nicht
aufholen werden wir mit der
verkehrswende glaube ich nicht
vorankommen jeder verletzte oder tote
radfahrer ist einer zu viel der druck
auf die politik wächst
jetzt nochmal nachrichten die gasanlage
bleibt ein großes thema
die eu kommission hat der
bundesregierung vorschläge gemacht wie
gaskunden in deutschland nicht zu stark
von der gas umlage belastet werden
können nachdem die ausnahme der
mehrwertsteuerbefreiung rechtlich nicht
möglich sei könne deutschland auch den
niedrigsten erlaubt mehrwertsteuersatz
von fünf prozent erheben oder die
zusätzlichen steuereinnahmen im
nachhinein zurückgeben thema an der
börse bleiben die massiven
herausforderungen eben der
energieversorger heute der enormen
verlust von 12 4 milliarden euro den
juniper im ersten halbjahr zu
verzeichnen hat bereits durch
staatshilfen vor der insolvenz gerettet
stellt sich die frage sina mainitz wie
kann es für juniper weitergehen
tatsächlich sehr ungewiss bei manchen am
parkett heißt es heute schon der konzern
stecke im auge des sturms der
europäischen energie krise es wird ein
langer und vor allem ein teurer weg
juniper zu retten der düsseldorfer
gashändler ist ein system relevanter
energieversorger und entsprechend groß
ist auch die sorge seit ende juli
bewahrt ein milliardenschweres
rettungspaket den konzern bereits vor
dem aus der verlust bei juniper beträgt
zwischen 60 und 100 millionen euro pro
tag wohlgemerkt auch deshalb ging es
heute für die aktien von deutschlands
größtem gasimporteur bergab ein minus
von zwölf prozent juniper erhält seit
mitte juni nur noch ein fünftel des
ursprünglich vereinbarten gases aus
russland beliefert aber mehr als 100
deutsche stadtwerke und industriefirmen
zum tagespreis muss das gas dann
anderswo teuer eingekauft werden damit
der konzern weiterhin liefern kann
bereits jetzt ist juniper zu 30 prozent
in staatlicher hand doch sowohl der
staat als auch gaskunden müssen
weiterhin einspringen die kunden zahlen
sogar doppelt über die gerade
verabschiedete gas umlage und über die
mehrwertsteuer energie los ging es heute
am deutschen aktienmarkt zu die
dax-kurve auf talfahrt und das
börsenbarometer tief in den roten zahlen
am ende ein verlust von mehr als zwei
prozent am markt sind eindeutig die
konjunktursorgen wieder zurückgekehrt
vielen dank sina mainitz
in zentral portugal fachen starke winde
die flammen bei dem verheerenden
waldbrand im unesco naturpark serra da
estrela weiter an mehr als 1200
feuerwehrleute sind auch mit
löschflugzeugen im einsatz inzwischen
sind rund 24.000 hektar wald zerstört
auch in der spanischen urlaubsregion
valencia breiten sich die flammen weiter
aus etwa 2000 menschen wurden in
sicherheit gebracht laut feuerwehr ist
es der schlimmste brand in der gegend
seit mehr als zehn jahren
fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen vom lotto
am mittwoch sie lauten ohne gewähr 1 17
34 44 46 superzahl 0 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 7
ein großer sport tag im zdf war das mit
vielen sportlichen highlights auf eines
müssen wir noch mal gesondert schauen am
goldenen mittwoch für die deutschen
schwimmer bei der europameisterschaft in
rom wurde sich zunächst das mixed duo im
synchronspringen den sieg tina punzel
und lou massenberg die beiden sind ein
sportliches paar am abend dann gab es
gold für ein echtes liebespaar zwei
athleten die getrennt antraten aber
gemeinsam siegten und das ist schon eine
besondere geschichte zeigt uns ralph
koschek
doppeltes glück doppeltes gold isabel
dose und lukas mertens ein traumpaar
dieser schwimm em seit diesem abend noch
viel mehr 2 die ein paar sind sich
gegenseitig beflügeln wie sie selbst
sagen innerhalb weniger minuten stehen
für die beiden ihre endläufe bei der
schwimm wm in rom an isabelle rose zuvor
schon silber und bronze erschwommen nun
das finale über 400 meter freistil und
große muss nicht nur gegen ihre starke
italienische konkurrent in simone korell
antreten sondern auch gegen den lärm von
5000 fans von vorne geht sie das rennen
an wissen über den schlussspurt der
italienerin eine taktik die aufgeht weil
sie die stehkraft hat und den vorsprung
hält bis zum anschlag
[Musik]
emotional herausfordernd dann das
unmittelbar danach an spannung pur denn
nun fiebert sie mit ihrem lebenspartner
lukas mertens
er hatte bereits silber über 800 meter
freistil und nun sein rennen über die
halbe distanz
mertens bleibt zunächst in lauerstellung
nach 150 metern aber übernimmt er die
führung und behält diese bis zum schluss
gold für mertens und auch der zweite
deutsche starter henning leitner
erfolgreich bronze
das macht er doch die erfahrung aus ich
sage mal vor einem jahr hätte ich noch
nie so souverän auftreten wir noch nie
so sicher einfach schwimmen können aber
ich denke das habe ich heute sehr gut
gemacht und jetzt kann man auch mal
feiern so endet ein römischer abend mit
goldenen momenten vor allem für ein ganz
besonderes paar isabelle rose und lukas
mertens ein abend den sie so schnell
nicht vergessen werden
toll das war es für heute ein paar
wechsel stehen an dem zdf und neue
aufgaben wirken sich auch an diesem
platz aus morgen begrüßt sie hier
nämlich anne gellinek die sie bisher aus
brüssel können künftig dann aus mainz
wir freuen uns drauf und sie sicher auch
gundula hält aber an dem platz die
stellungen und meldet sich auch um 0.25
mit unserem heute-journal updates direkt
nach markus lanz an denen ich sehe jetzt
sehr gerne weitergeben schönen abend
noch tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend heute zogen schauer und
gewitter vor allen dingen über die
westhälfte deutschlands und jetzt am
abend gab es vor allen dingen zwei
schwerpunkte zum einen in
norddeutschland in den vergangenen drei
stunden sind hier gewitter über hamburg
weiter nordwärts gezogen haben
inzwischen kiel und die ostseeküste
erreicht und dann gab es auch gewitter
von frankreich aus der schweiz her die
zogen hier über dem schwarzwald und über
die schwäbische alb und eine
gewitterzelle ist auch vom allgäu weiter
nordwärts gezogen diese gewitter werden
noch in den nächsten paar stunden
herumtoben aber dann fallen sie in sich
zusammen und dann fällt eigentlich nur
noch regen hier im südwesten
deutschlands die gewitter im norden
ziehen auch nordwärts ab bis zum frühen
morgen sinken die temperaturen an der
ostsee und in der uckermark auf 19 grad
14 grad werden ist am alpenrand und in
den westlichen mittelgebirgen
am morgen liegen die höchsttemperaturen
im südwesten bei 22 bis 27 grad in
berlin und brandenburg wird es dagegen
noch mal heiß mit 34 35 grad morgen
vormittag geht schon dichtere wolken
hier in der mitte deutschlands da kann
es häufiger regnen aber die kräftige
schauer und gewitter entwickeln sich
erst am späten nachmittag zum abend hier
so zwischen dem thüringer wald und
berlin/brandenburg vielleicht blitzt es
auch mal an der ostsee und auch in
bayern und in baden württemberg gibt es
gewitter am freitag und am samstag droht
dann am alpenrand dauerregen da können
innerhalb von zwei tagen 100 liter regen
pro quadratmeter herunter kommen es
drohen sturzbäche und überflutungen von
nordwesten beruhigt sich die lage guten
abend